with the holiday weekend here how do we
enjoy it safely for that and the latest
coronavirus numbers we're joined by dr.
amos adul gist senior scholar at the
Johns Hopkins center for health security
dr. Dahl juh good morning first off you
know State Health Department officials
are urging Americans to stay at home
this holiday weekend but you know a lot
of folks already have their plans so
what's the message what's the message to
those who will certainly be out
celebrating this holiday the message is
that every time you take any activity in
the air of the pandemic there's always
going to be some risk of either you
transmitting or acquiring this virus and
that doesn't mean you have to stay at
home and not do anything it just means
that you cannot act as if we're not in
the pandemic you need to try and follow
as much as possible social distancing
rules washing your hands a lot not
touching your face wearing face
coverings as needed in order to minimize
that risk of you acquiring it or
spreading the virus to someone and this
is the new normal going forward until
there is a vaccine so we have to get
used to living in this type of era where
there is this risk every time we step
out the door a majority of states are
seeing an increase in cases certain
areas significantly some states are also
seeing a rise in hospitalizations what
do you expect the month of July to look
like it's probably going to look just as
it has has it looked at the late in late
June meaning that we're going to see
more cases we're going to see more hot
spots pop up and the key question will
be will we see hospitals getting under
stress and I think that's what we have
to keep in mind and that's what we're
trying to avoid is some kind of a repeat
of what happened in the early days of
this pandemic where we were worried
about personal protective equipment
mechanical ventilators we haven't heard
so much about that but there are some
hospitals in Arizona for example in
Houston in Florida work where we are
thinking about what how are they going
to sustain this surge of patients and I
think that's what we have to keep in
mind is that we can we know we're gonna
get cases we just have to keep them to a
level that's manageable by the health
departments and hospitals through
contact tracing so we don't go into this
kind of crisis mode again doctor we've
seen a number of states implement some
form of mandatory mask wearing in public
do you believe all states should
implement that right now we have many
people out there that have very mild
symptoms maybe no symptoms at all and
they might be contagious
and what a face covering can do is
decrease the source can actually serves
a source control so that you're less
likely to spread it so I do think while
we have all of these people out there it
makes sense to take this simple measure
in order to stop transmission from
occurring and it doesn't necessarily
have to be a mask it could be a face
shield as well so I think that there are
there are a couple of options here but I
do think now that the consensus is that
this is one way to decrease the spread
because there's so many people that
don't even realize that they're infected
that are out there also one actually
doctor you've recently written about the
need for at home at home diagnostic
testing why is that important for right
now and also in the future well we've
had this whole pandemic really be marred
by testing failure after testing Fillion
we're still talking about testing even
though now we're doing 600,000 tests per
day home diagnostic testing is a way to
really empower patients to be able to
test themselves and and it would
alleviate lines at testing centers it's
a it's a whole new paradigm of thinking
about how we might manage infectious
disease emergencies in the in the future
we do this for HIV and there is
technology for influenza out there and
it could easily be adapted to
coronaviruses in areas there is a lot of
political will now so I think we could
call on some of Congress and funders to
try and push this type of technology
forward because it will be something
that would change the way we think about
pandemics give us so much more awareness
of what viruses are out there and I
think it would really empower patients
to take their health into their own
hands okay interesting to hear about
that the question I guess is how long it
would take dr. I Miche I told you thank
you very much for your time thank you